distinguished guests and dear friends
welcome to this wonderful school on this
beautiful island of villages I can think
of no more fitting occasion for the
first ever visit to Gozo by a president
of the European commission a few good
days ago at the United Nations General
Assembly I set out my mission to get the
future right I spoke of how we need to
take the right decisions to be on top of
the challenges ahead answering those
challenges this new school is indeed a
concrete example of owning the future of
turning challenges into opportunities
through leadership when the pandemic hit
us way back in 2020 m
and godo were hit harder than most when
with tourism at a standstill our Islands
which usually welcome so many tourists
were particularly impacted that's why
when President Von Delan proposed the
recovery and resilience facility Malta
was engaged from the start because Malta
shares with the president the Deep
belief that only by committing to fully
embracing the coming green and digital
transitions will we be able to truly
build back
better so I was delighted when the
commission agreed to malta's plans and
even more delighted still when on your
last visit to our country you had
described malta's recovery plan as one
of the greenest which any member state
had submitted that Delight continues
today here in godo as we visit pupils
and Educators that have commenced only a
few days ago this Scholastic year in new
classes with new facilities we are
delivering a new school built on the
same footprint on which the previous one
was built because we believe that our
land use policy is an integral part of
our sustainability policy utilizing the
next genu funds to deliver real
practical benefit to all godsons the
figures are also very impressive overall
Malta is benefiting from more than 300
million euro to speed up our economic
growth over half of that is supporting
our climate objectives and a quarter our
digital
transformation but these fine sounding
games only matter if if they are
translated into tangible projects on the
ground across our communities projects
that equip local people with the skills
of the future that use the green
technology of the future and build our
economic capacity for the future nadur
School represents and symbolizes such a
project utilizing over6 million EUR 6.3
million euro of NextGen EU investment to
deliver new facilities to enhance the
education of the next generation of
godan students only by providing the
best education to our pupils can we
promote social Mobility which in turn
creates more peaceful and equal
societies this project will have a new
dance studio a music room A literacy
room and also an art studio studio all
built in a sustainable manner U
utilizing the latest energy efficient
technology to deliver a carbon neutral
building a win for pupil a win also for
the environment a win for godo and Malta
I would here like to pay tribute to the
roles of Education Minister Clifton GMA
Chris Bonnet parliamentary secretary
responsible for European funds and also
nville young thank you nville who is the
chief officer of the foundation for
tomorrow schools for delivering such an
amazing project in a timely manner
president dear Ursula I know you are
aware of the dangers of isolation for
the more remote parts of Europe like me
you agree that connectivity is key to
ensuring that geography isn't a barrier
to economic success my government is
fully determined that godo's location
should be turned into a positive Gozo
will never be left behind and will never
play second fiddle that's why my
government has already increased by a
quarter godo's share of the long-term EU
funds allocated to our nation I say to
all godz itans we shall ensure that godo
will always get its fair share to meet
the green Target the green targets at
the very heart of our recovery plan
that's why we've committed to making
Gozo the first carbon neutral zone in
our Islands delivering visible benefits
and improving everyday life like the
green transport Hub at SHI only a a
short distance away from here designed
to enhance connectivity for godzin by
reducing congestion at the vital mjar
Harbor with sustainability at its core
electric buses free to use as is all our
public transport connecting passengers
to the hardar transforming a site there
contaminated with illegally damed
material into a green roof desert goo
here again proudly showing the way Gozo
may very well be a small island but its
people are extremely hardworking with
Clint ceri as Minister for goo goo
enjoys an energetic champion in my
government focused on delivering where
it matters to enhancing people's
well-being and prosperity dear Ursula
thank you for finding the time to visit
godo and I am very proud to share with
you these projects observing the impact
of our shared commitment to building
green growth it is that agenda of green
growth alongside other vital issues such
as migration that will be Central to the
discussions and decisions at the m 9
meeting which Malta will be hosting
later on today Malta and the EU working
together delivering a difference driving
the change our Islands need addressing
the challenges getting our nation ready
for tomorrow in short getting the future
right thank you
[Applause]
thank
you thank you very much prime minister
dear Robert ministers excellencies
ladies and gentlemen dear
students It's a Wonderful opportunity
and many many thanks for the warm
welcome to be here in goo and to visit
the nadur primary school school first of
all after you showed me the classrooms
and the work you're doing I want to pay
tribute to pay tribute to the teachers
and the staff here at the school and of
course to the students for the great
work that is being done here you could
just feel it it's tangible that there's
a very good atmosphere and it's
heartwarming and wonderful to see that
you're working with the children here
basically Paving their way into the
future so I thank you from the bottom of
my heart for this outstanding work
teachers in general are doing thank you
very much for that the school is indeed
brand new although the whole building
has been preserved the historic building
it has been completely
renovated with funds from Next
Generation EU and I'm very glad to see
that it is now highly energy
efficient it has has spacious
classrooms it has a better air quality
the air condition is powered by the
schools's own solar panels that's smart
you have sun in abundance you can use it
and we could see the new digital
equipment so that was amazing also to
see how modern and digitized the school
now is the Children looked very much at
ease and as I said it's heartwarming to
see that the environment plays a big
role how you're going into life in your
school and how the teaching is
successful now this indeed has been
financed under Next Generation you and
this is a great project for the islands
of Malta and goo and I know you have
many more projects like this in the
pipeline Next Generation EU our
investment plan is investing 330 million
EUR here in Malta and in goo and in
indeed you have chosen to dedicate
almost 70% of this investment to climate
objectives this is way more than the
European average that's excellent and I
really want to thank you for that you
are among the first countries to
increase the share of Renewables in your
energy mix and renewable energy is
homegrown it gives you Independence as I
said you have the re resources in
abundance that's sun and wind so this
will help strengthen the electricity
grid here and this is so important
especially considering the power cuts
that were here in the summer you told me
about it and where we want to work on
together that this does not happen
anymore and one of the ingredients for a
solution is to indeed strengthen the
Renewable Energy System so Malta needs
basically to combine its strong growth
that that's good with sustainable use of
its natural resources that's good too
and to combine and reconcile both that's
our common Endeavor and task I know it's
a challenge but I'm also here today to
tell you that Europe is at your sight
and uh all along the road I was in Malta
two years ago to launch the recovery and
resilience plan and it's good to see
already two years later the results of
the work that we've SP started back then
because this is just the beginning we
will continue working on other great
projects so there's lot lots of good
projects in the
pipeline being here in goo is also a
great way to start the summit of the
med9 thank you very much for the
invitation throughout history Malta has
played a strategic role in the
Mediterranean region Malta with its
unique cultural heritage it's amazing to
see here and we are way too short here
to take in all the amazing Treasures you
have here and with your cultural
heritage you project our European values
in the
Mediterranean and it represents all the
opportunities for trade and investment
in renewable energy that the
Mediterranean had has to offer at the
summit we will have important
discussions on the future of the
Mediterranean region and there is no
better place to have these discussions
then here at the Crossroad of Europe
Africa and the Middle East so thank you
very much again for the very warm
welcome and many thanks for the
opportunity to visit this school many
thanks again to the staff and the
teachers and many thanks for the
children to show all that thank you
well done well
done